Andrew Klavan is a contributing editor
at City Journal he just sort of peace
that has been pinging around the
internet like Samus Dada it's responding
to President Trump's immigration remarks
and he joins us tonight Andrew thanks a
lot for coming on this is one of these
pieces that probably one in three of our
viewers got by text this weekend but I
just want to read the first line which
kind of crystallizes it
nothing scandalizes a leftist like the
truth that's your opening what does that
mean well the left has been tremendously
successful in making the statement of
simple facts seem rude and evil and
unkind so if you come forward and you
say well men and women are different and
have different desires and different
career paths if you say that
african-americans commit a
disproportionate amount of violent
crimes if you say that Muslims commit a
disproportionate amount of terrorism
suddenly they rear back and they start
to call you a bigot they start to say
you're racist or sexist or Islamophobic
or whatever until the the statement of
simple data things that are just
factually true become unexpressable
you're not allowed to say them and I
don't think conservatives fully
appreciate the the power of that kind of
mental slavery conservatives are not
very good with culture and we don't
understand the way it wraps itself
around your mind and keeps you from
saying the things that you're thinking
but shouldn't all American citizens
regardless of political party or
philosophy just by virtue of being
American demand to live by the standard
we always have live by which is truth as
a defense you may not like it but if
it's true I have the right to say it
it shouldn't we stand by that yes and
usually you know it used to be that the
First Amendment and the fact that
Americans just tend to be kind of
loudmouths and say what comes into their
heads and it used to protect us but the
left has been exceptionally good at
making sure I mean look we've learned
just last week the Twitter's shadow back
banning conservatives we've seen how
Google fires a guy who states something
that's politically incorrect we've seen
Prager University videos banned on
YouTube we know that there is this
massive and when conservative speakers
go to universities there are met by
violent resistance even if they're very
intelligent people like ben shapiro or
charles murray they met with violent
resistance the left is very intent on
silencing right-wing opinion and it's
very powerful I mean you look over
what's happening in Europe where their
immigration policy since the war have
virtually destroyed their culture people
who come out there and say well you know
maybe Islam doesn't fit in England maybe
it doesn't fit in some of the
Scandinavian countries are destroyed
there they were made into pariahs as a
result we saw how in Rotherham in
England at a conservative estimate 1400
little girls were raped by Pakistani
Muslims because the police themselves
didn't want to come out and call them
out and say they were afraid of being
called racist so they allowed this
atrocity to continue one of the things
that I see when I look at Donald Trump
I'm a very polite guy and I'm a guy who
doesn't like to offend people just like
most of us one of the things I see that
actually works for Donald Trump is his
rudeness and his boorishness actually
have shattered this prison of political
correctness that the left has managed to
construct and I think that's the reason
that every word that comes out of his
mouth and every tweet that he sends out
he's such a scandal I mean if you turn
on CNN over the weekend after his
remarks about Haiti and African
countries every one of their anchormen
was crying you know their little
trembling lips and the misty eyes
because it was so intolerable that to
them that Donald Trump was not
restrained by their definition of what's
cruel and their definition of what's
impolite this is a network where
Anderson Cooper called ordinary
right-wing Americans he called them tea
baggers and now when Hades insulted
suddenly Anderson his lip is trembling
and his eyes are all misty it's a form
of bullying it's a it's simply a form of
social bullying and I'm grateful for
Donald Trump for shattering that even
when he does it in ways that I find kind
of appalled yeah I agree completely
societies that hate themselves this much
tend to collapse and so I'm glad you're
fighting true a tendency thank you
Andrew thanks a lot that's really a
great piece a pleasure